let's lose the tude please losing
the tude speaking of disasters dad we
are leaving you
in charge yeah but that's kind of on
beth right why would she ever leave rick
in charge of her children or
really anything this garage door falls
outwards after the center is dissolved
by alien eels except the hinges weren't
destroyed so this is a sin for the
animators not making a couple of heels
dissolve the hinges
and a sin for the writers for forcing
the door to fall in order to kick off
the rest of the episode
well we're past the point of no return
bridget fonda shaming using your binder
incorrectly
or writing math upside down and
backwards on the back panel of a binder
for no reason
either way a sin does that say
multi-grain legs
i guess they sell peanuts in a box and
abbreviate legumes to legs
none of this seems appetizing more
profitable just keep your sci-fi friends
away from my awesome one
how about you all focus and just keep
that refrigerator door closed while you
carry on conversations and
then work on your strategic segregation
and you keep your awesome friends away
from my canapes
when the canopy tray came out of the
fridge every one of them had a green
olive
why would rick remove one just to add it
back in dramatic fashion
i love watching [ __ ] i mean like i
don't know if i personally would ever do
it
[ __ ] how many people did you invite
rick better question
of the many that rick invited how many
are going to want to get downstairs
schwifty with summer's questionably aged
peer group
looks like the garage door was instantly
fixed i love seeing aliens and humans
hanging out together despite their
differences but
how are none of the people freaking out
right now being a morty at a high school
party casually watching a murder meal
knock it off slow mobius if slow mobius
didn't stop using his slow-mo powers
until rick said something
why was rick able to speak at a normal
pace running on deck
also stealing this [ __ ] doesn't feel
solid objects in his liquid and
that is [ __ ] concerning they weren't
the size of ants they were ice cube
sized beings
summer don't tell me you're friends with
her popular controlling girl is pretty
and demands your normal looking friend
to be sacrificed on the altar of
conformity cliche
i just want to find somebody nice and
sweet which somehow prompts morty to
show her a deadly mad scientist garage
rather than the toy collection in his
room apparently the garage door wasn't
fixed in now i'm curious about the sign
story where the door was dissolved by
eels fixed before the party but then
immediately redissolved tarped taped
tacked and held in place by
bullsh house teleports to a different
planet that happens to have oxygen an
immediate hook up to power
cliche you see jerry may i show you
something i was lucy not been caught yet
the operation doesn't seem to be that
large and she's wearing a maid's outfit
no one has questioned why she's
fraternizing with a guest instead of
cleaning or picking up
rick's using a credit card to turn these
crystals into something snortable but
what's with the number on this thing
one two three four one two three four it
can't be a show that revels in the
details and then not expect a nitpicker
to examine stuff like this
come up with a plausible number you
jerks move to the left
that's the right step to the right
that's the left
that somehow everyone knows instantly
also river dance did it first
the floor drops out to make it easier
we're going to get it
nice and steamy in there with with the
floor kicked out
well at least you got all this free
stuff equating free stuff is an
agreeable result of being the victim of
a sexual assault it's not a door beth
it's debris
i don't care just leave it yeah okay
this door can fit in the front seat so
there's no reason it shouldn't be able
to fit in the back of their wagon with a
little rearranging
[Music]
somehow despite the window being down in
the ear piercing volume of her
horrible laugh neither of these [ __ ]
hear her
explaining your references since
everything came back as it previously
was
where did the rest of this gate go
pulling down someone's pants while they
are frozen midstep wouldn't be this easy
in reality these pants would get stuck
at the waist and top of the thigh don't
ask me how i know this
not using the ramp for your cart filled
with expensive electronics and yes
it is stolen but it's still valuable
not until i hear you say rixxy business
or rick and morty rick
not until
why is this boner
i'm sorry but i didn't build you a
stronger ship
young rose sinners go vows to our newest
domain of
nitpick delights and behold commercial
sins
oh and subscribe immediately so the
order goes click sub simple as that
oh actually watch the video jesus i
guess i need to make a flow chart
commercial signs go now
speaking of disasters dad we are leaving
you in charge
ooh someone has a serious face on
it smells like thai food in here have
you guys been [ __ ]
every weekend jackson roses have their
titanic experience in this car
and i have to mop it up oh that's not
right
i'm still alive but i'm very badly
injured the beacon was activated
and rohan will answer